hi i'm going to be talking to you today
about hacking rfid attendance systems to
be in two places at once
our story begins in the spring of 2020
with an unnamed 18 year old computer
science undergrad student
with just two requirements left he's
about to become the youngest ever
computer science graduate from his
university unfortunately as he's
registering for his final semester of
classes he realizes that his two
remaining courses are both scheduled at
basically the same time but surprisingly
he was able to register just fine at the
time the scheduling system only checked
whether classes were at the exact same
start time not whether they overlapped
at all so he registered for both classes
and thought problem solved i'm in the
student may or may not have actually
been attending his classes regularly
anyways so how one can be present in two
simultaneous classes was not a top of
mind
and a quick look at the course syllabi
revealed that between 10 and 15 of the
points were for attendance this means
that missing half or even all of the
lectures shouldn't have been the end of
the world it wasn't until the week
before classes started that he decided
to look more closely and he was
surprised to find a new policy that
students with more than six unexcused
absences would not be allowed to pass
the course they would have to retake it
well this was an issue because he was so
close to graduating and he was about to
set a record after all
so he started thinking about how these
courses actually enforce their
attendance policies what do these large
universities use to keep track of
attendance for thousands of students
well it turns out that this is what they
use it's an rfid based polling system
that has become increasingly popular at
universities due to the ease of
conducting attendance for even large
classes with hundreds of students every
student in the course will be assigned
one of these a remote with the unique
identifier linked to their student
account
then throughout the lecture instructors
will ask multiple choice questions and
have students respond by pressing the
corresponding button on their remote the
remote will then broadcast their answer
along with their student id back to the
base station so that after class
instructors can generate a list of
students in attendance along with the
answer they chose so it actually serves
a dual purpose both enforcing attendance
by requiring students to actually show
up with their remote but also serving as
a small quiz each lecture to make sure
students are paying attention well it
would seem that this system should make
it impossible to attend two lectures at
the same time even if a student were to
give his remote to a classmate to answer
for him in one of the lectures he then
wouldn't have the remote to answer with
himself in another lecture
so if he's going to make this work he
better get creative
what he could do is try attending one
class then attending the other class
alternating which one he attends and
which one he misses but that only gets
him till the end of february until he's
used up all his drops so that doesn't
exactly work
okay but maybe he could try clicking in
in one class then sprinting across
campus to the other lecture and clicking
in there then sprinting back before the
next question starts
but our mystery student isn't exactly
usain bolt so that one might not work
either what he really needed was a time
turner it's this magical device from the
harry potter series that the students
used to take two classes at the same
time by time traveling now without the
luxury of magic he would need the next
best thing which is of course hacking
specifically hacking this system the one
that actually enforces his attendance if
he can get this system to mark him
present in both classes he would in
effect be in two places at once
well the bad news is that this remote
uses completely proprietary hardware and
software to communicate with the base
station the good news is that hackers
exist so of course it was quickly
reverse engineered by some colleagues of
mine at cornell
i've added some links here to their
original paper and it's definitely worth
the read but for now i'm going to
outline the techniques they use to
approach reverse engineering this system
and then i'll explain what they found
and how it could be exploited by our
hypothetical student
this is actually a fairly simple device
with only two significant ics the first
being an 8-bit microcontroller
manufactured by nxp and the second being
a 915 megahertz ism transceiver
manufactured by semtech
all one has to do to monitor the
communications between these two
components is tap into the data pins for
the spi bus here
which is exactly what my colleagues did
to sniff the data in transit between the
two ics it's important to note that the
manufacturer of this device prevented
the firmware from being directly
analyzed by burning the security program
fuse they didn't however do this on an
earlier version of the device so that
firmware is now available online
another thing my colleagues did was just
packet sniff the rf signals to see what
the device was emitting directly a
waterfall plot for the answer a is shown
here it seems like the device is just
broadcasting a single short packet for
each response using two fsk modulation
at a bit rate of 152 kilobits per second
the base station then sends back a
single acknowledgement packet although
this is less important for our use case
the base station and the remote appear
to negotiate a single fixed frequency
for transmitting and one for receiving
depending on what channel they're set to
use although in practice it's almost
always just a a
now knowing the frequency and the
encoding scheme the researchers simply
pressed each of the buttons a through e
and observed what the contents of the
resulting answer packet were which are
shown here
surprisingly the packets that the remote
sends to the base station are just five
bytes long which is just barely enough
space to encode a device serial number
and an answer with maybe a checksum so
there can't be that much more than that
going on
additionally the only the final two
bytes of each packet actually change
when the answer changes so this must be
the portion of the message which encodes
the selected answer the first three
bytes of the packet are always the same
which must mean that this is the portion
that encodes the device id so let's look
at this part first
it turns out that what's happening here
is just a basic transposition cipher
that shuffles the bits of the device id
according to a predetermined and easily
reversible system
it also turns out that the device ids
which have eight hexadecimal digits
contain a rudimentary built-in checksum
whereby the fourth byte is just the xor
of the first three bytes
just by reversing the process in this
table we can now construct the first
part of the answer packet for any valid
device id
now let's look at the last two bytes of
this message the fourth byte of the
message just encodes the answer choice
according to a predetermined table
and the fifth and final byte is a
checksum of the entire message according
to this algorithm
we now have everything we need to
reconstruct the entire protocol which is
shown here
all that's left to do is to build a
device that can emulate the legitimate
remote and it turns out that this 25
adafruit feather m0 board has all of the
hardware necessary to accomplish this
the firmware that i wrote to emulate the
polling system is linked here along with
a tutorial for how to set it up the
entire firmware compiles down to less
than 10 kilobytes and can comfortably
reside in the arduino's built-in flash
storage
but enough talking about it let's see it
in action
all right now for a brief demo on my
left is the legitimate polling system
and as always if i select an answer on
my remote it'll be broadcast and
received by the base station
on my right is an arduino running the
custom firmware and initialize to a
random serial number it's connected to
my laptop right now with the usb so i
can manually send it commands and if i
instruct it to broadcast an answer as if
it were a remote right now it'll look to
the base station as though another
student is submitting an answer using
their remote
now let's try this again but this time
i'm going to set the arduino to the same
serial number as my remote now if i
click in with the remote as normal and
then instruct the arduino to broadcast
an answer
it appears to the base station as though
the same student is simply changing
their response
in effect these two devices are acting
as if they are the same remote
as it stands though this only addresses
half our problem because although our
student would now be able to transmit
answers as if he were using a real
remote he still wouldn't know which
answer choice was correct without being
physically present and frankly even then
it's questionable luckily by reverse
engineering this protocol it becomes as
easy to emulate a base station as it is
a remote simply by setting the packet
radio on the m0 to receive mode rather
than transmit this would then allow him
to see what other students are answering
and simply choose the most popular
response
okay same demo as before except this
time my arduino is set up to emulate a
base station so when a student submits
an answer it's overheard not just by the
legitimate base station but also by the
arduino which can then nicely display
all of the student selections on my
laptop alright well obviously we don't
want to have to keep manually
controlling this device luckily if we
combine the last two demonstrations it's
not hard to imagine a fairly basic
protocol for automating this process we
should start by instructing the device
to remain idle until the expected start
time of the class
then it should turn on and start
emulating both a base station and a
remote
it should wait until a flurry of
radioactivity occurs indicating the
likely start of a new question it should
then use the base station emulator to
determine what the most popular student
response is at which point it should use
the remote emulator to broadcast that
same response it should repeat those
steps until the expected end time of the
class thereby answering every question
and most of them correctly so now we're
getting somewhere but this is not
exactly a practical solution it has to
remain tethered to a pc and manually
controlled
the first step towards a completely
self-contained solution is to attach a
standalone input device which i've done
here by crudely soldering on a 128 by 32
pixel oled screen with three input
buttons
the really nice thing about using an
ultra low power platform like arduino is
that this device even with a display
attached has a peak current draw of
about
20 milliamps as you can see here
so this tiny 500 milliamp hour lithium
polymer battery should last well over 24
hours on a single charge if i connect
this up we now have something resembling
a practical self-contained device
here's the same device just with a
little uh electrical tape added to hold
everything together this finished device
is what i call my time turner it bears
not much resemblance to the original but
it can achieve many of the same results
let me show you the most basic thing i
can do with this time turner device is
just submit a vote as if i were using a
legitimate remote as you can see the
base station here still can't tell the
difference
another thing i can do is view the votes
of my classmates it might be hard to see
this screen but no matter which option i
choose on this legitimate remote it is
automatically displayed on the time
turner
now if i were more nefarious what i
could do is try to change the votes of
my classmates i'm going to restart the
poll here
and this time no matter what my
classmate chooses their vote will
automatically be changed to be
let's try picking an answer
and no matter what i choose it is
automatically overwritten by the time
turner device
now a vulnerability that allows me to
change someone else's vote on a
so-called polling system is a major
oversight
but if i were more nefarious still i
could simply perform a denial of service
attack submitting hundreds of votes per
second will quickly overwhelm the host
device eventually causing it to crash
and making it impossible for a
legitimate student to submit their vote
let's restart this poll one last time to
show the most relevant type of attack
which is simply copying the most popular
vote for any given question
so i'm going to restart the polling and
this time the time turner will just copy
whatever the most popular vote is so
let's say i vote for a as a legitimate
device the time turner immediately
copies that
if the most popular vote changes to
something else the time turner will
eventually change its vote always making
sure to stay within the majority the
idea is that with just a little adhesive
putty the student can go in the previous
night and covertly attach this device to
some surface in the lecture hall and you
can be sure that the next morning this
device will attend class for him while
he attends the other class the normal
way
of course if he can do this then he
could just as easily build two devices
and attach them both the surfaces in the
lecture halls and then these will both
attend class for him and he can
catch up on homework or sleep in
now i'm not going to tell you if this
student eventually just built these for
all of his classes but
i'll let you come to your own conclusion
on that one
what i can tell you is that this device
was pretty darn effective and by
mid-semester the student had almost full
points in both attendance and quiz
correctness so what does that tell us
about this
first of all it's a great lesson about
authentication
you may already know that an
authentication mechanism should either
be something you know like a password
something you have like a universal
second factor key
or something you are like your biometric
data
these factors are all in theory unique
to you
but this is just a polling device it's
being used incorrectly to authenticate
someone's physical presence at a lecture
when in fact there's no real
authentication happening here at all
it's just broadcasting an answer and an
id number in plain text over a radio
signal
now to their credit they did try to hide
this by using a proprietary protocol
that shuffles the bits around but i mean
this is an obvious violation of
kirchhoff's principle which states that
a system should be secure even if
everything except the key is public
knowledge
when using security through obscurity
it's only a matter of time until someone
completely reverse engineers your system
and what little security you had
disappears
so now that the security flaws of this
particular system have come to light
let's talk about the various
shortcomings of its design and how they
might be addressed
i think the flaws of this system map
cleanly onto the three so-called cia
properties which are confidentiality
integrity and availability i'll recount
what i see as the core issues with this
system and then propose a simple way to
fix each of them
first with regards to confidentiality
there's none to speak of as i
demonstrated when we were able to listen
in to other students answers
next is integrity and again because i
was able to build a device that could
indistinguishably emulate my own or
anyone else's remote and even change
other people's answers the integrity of
the answers received by a base station
cannot be assured
and finally with respect to availability
i demonstrated a simple denial of
service attack that would make it
difficult for a legitimate remote to be
heard
and now as promised some proposed
solutions starting with availability
this one is pretty straightforward every
single remote in a classroom is
transmitting and receiving on the exact
same frequencies
for the default a8 channel that's about
916
and 903 megahertz respectively
one would actually expect far more
natural collisions and packet drops if
each honest remote wasn't broadcasting
just five bytes at a time
but it does make the system particularly
vulnerable to denial of service attacks
as we saw
perhaps a better idea would be to use
fhss whereby the frequency used by a
given remote rapidly changes in a way
that is predictable to the base station
but not to any passive observer
standardized protocols like bluetooth
already implement this by default and
that's for a good reason it's still not
impossible to jam but it becomes much
harder and requires wide spectrum radio
frequency jamming which is very
expensive and very illegal that's not to
say that any of these attacks are
particularly legal if you're not using
your own system like i am here
next confidentiality which is also not
too tricky one way to address this would
be for the base station and remote to
perform an authenticated key exchange
when they first establish a connection
and then use the symmetric session key
to encrypt all communications moving
forward
something like mutual off tls could be
used to do this in a standardized way in
fact the chip used by this device
already has built-in hardware support
for aes encryption but it was
intentionally disabled for whatever
reason
and again standard protocols like
bluetooth would already do this by
default although the mechanism there is
a bit more intricate
finally integrity this is the trickiest
problem to solve but one idea might be
to use a physically unclonable function
or puff a laser-based design is shown
here but silicon puffs can be had for a
few dollars and it would make it nearly
impossible for me to build another
device that replicates the behavior of
my remote or the remote of any other
student for that matter
this still doesn't solve the broader
problem of authenticating physical
presence due to the possibility of
relaying answers from a legitimate
device to one or more remote locations
to combat this you would need to add a
challenge response mechanism with a
tight time window
just large enough for devices in close
proximity to submit a response a matter
of microseconds but not nearly what it
would take to actually relay a message
over the internet which would be at
least a few milliseconds
a student or at least their real remote
would therefore have to actually be in
the room in order to respond to the
challenges sent by the base station fast
enough for their attendance to come
all right let's summarize it's hard to
overstate how vulnerable this system is
and it's even more shocking that this
exact model is currently used at over
1100 universities and in nearly a
hundred thousand classrooms
to summarize my security recommendations
if a new version of this system were
released they should consider using fhss
to avoid denial of service attacks and
use encryption and transit to protect
confidentiality
bonus points if these first two problems
are both solved by simply using an open
source standard which satisfies
kirchhoff's principle lastly they should
use a puff with a time challenge
response mechanism to produce what would
then be an incredibly secure device
especially by comparison to its current
form well it turns out that the
authentication problem may be even worse
than it seems that's because in addition
to the student remote the same company
also produces an instructor remote that
allows teachers to start and stop
pulling show and hide the poll results
switch slides on a powerpoint
presentation and even select the correct
quiz answer
now if these devices look similar that's
because they're actually identical under
the hood so it's as easy to emulate this
instructor remote as it was to emulate
this student remote and once one can do
that they can do everything from
changing these slides on the
instructor's presentation to even
selecting their own quiz answers as
correct which really emphasizes the need
for a paw for some other hardware-based
authentication mechanism now it needs to
be emphasized that puffs and bluetooth
chips are already bulk produced
commodity hardware that cost a few
dollars at the most
after all this is a 54 device so it's
hard to argue that there is a major cost
barrier here by the way this one is
about 30 dollars if you already have a
soldering iron
as for our canonical student well as i
mentioned all of this was taking place
in the spring of 2020 and around the
same time another major world event was
starting to unfold
so of course midway through the semester
he ends up receiving this email which
among other things tells him that all of
his classes have been moved online and
that all students will get full
participation points so while this
didn't end up being helpful hopefully it
at least made for an interesting defcon
talk as for these days well if a student
wanted to attend two classes at once
today this is how they would do it
thank you